why why should I have to deal with your
your issues after you've just you had
the chance when you was 21 the chance
when you was 22 23 no I want to go Club
I want to do this
please babes I want a wife for you no no
no no I ain't got time for you you know
on account free everyone shout out their
body count five but do you get my point
did you get my point
no you're not ashamed of it because it's
five yeah if it was 55 you'd stay quiet
yeah yeah no you would stay quiet
if I was 55 it wouldn't have it wouldn't
necessarily me staying quiet because we
know what the um
what it's like like it's not it's not a
bad thing necessarily for me to be
sleeping around can I just say something
that I am
myself obviously I've had long-term
relationships so I'm fine but
what I will say is for the younger
generation
it's very difficult to have a low body
count now because and it's it's because
of older women not even you lie to the
younger women
can I just let me just say something
you've got time like you're staying
dating and we're staying connections and
we're giving out all this there's so
many people the social media has ruined
dating it's like there's so much variety
there's so much what you should be
expecting what you shouldn't be
expecting so it's so fickle dating is so
fickle now how how are young girls
expected to keep their body count down
when
there's there's no relationships now
like it's not like back in the day where
you had a long-term like relationship
mostly our age were the last of the
long-term relationships I'm not gonna
lie well men men have definitely dropped
their standards for what they used to
accept a girl used to be a hoe she slept
with more than two people now a guy
praised for five
and I've seen I've seen guys I've seen a
lot of hoes got wifed a lot that's true
but they're also the first divorced
because I always say a woman sleeping
around it hurts herself more than anyone
else because it impacts her ability to
pair bond
so women have a hard time staying when
they've slept with too many people
statistically because yeah because women
that have slept with more than five men
their their chance of a happy marriage
drops from at one eighty percent after
10 years they're going to be in a happy
marriage too 30 after five Partners
after 10 years so I can't sleep with any
more guys or else I'm gonna drop in the
present it's not that nice like what so
I need to find myself
but that's what I'm saying is like
there's reasons behind it do you think
do you think that's gonna work
no more sex yeah do you like that's what
I mean when I say you making him wait
and you're making no way
like that it's like now I'm I'm on my
I'm on my no I'm just gonna have to go
back to someone I've had sex with yeah
that's why I asked you should have
married your partner
I know you explained it to me but that's
why at first I said you should have
married your partner yeah you did if you
married your partner in year one you
would have divorced when your problems
happened but you would have been married
I don't listen I grew up yeah I grew up
let me let me give you this I don't know
if it's my cousin's fault I blame her
um I was a Protestant in Scotland as
Protestant Catholics my cousin was a
Catholic as a Protestant she got to make
her communion and I didn't
she religiously I stayed at her house
and most days when my mum was working
she used to dress me in a trouser suit
and she dressed up in her communion
dress and made us play weddings like in
the living room in front of everyone and
it really daunted me that she always
made me be the guy like her it hurt me a
lot so I just was like I hate weddings I
don't know if it's instilled I haven't
ever had the wish to be married I don't
dream of the white dress I don't do it
the commitment that is for the
government to say you're married like I
dream of real love like that's all I've
ever done but marriage marriage is a
business and it's a business you're
right and when I left I realized that I
failed in that business transaction yeah
because he held most of the month the
money but I think that's like the what
we have confused as women is we're in it
for love but it's not about love it's
about what works long-term in building
family and I hear you and I hear you and
I hear what you're saying and for my my
beautiful daughters I did say a lot a
lot a lot longer than I should have a
lot longer but when they got to a
certain age and maturity and I realized
that this was actually affecting them
because I didn't want what I realized is
I thought was acceptable because I'd
seen my parents
do the similar things so I thought that
was acceptable I'd never seen I've never
I'd never seen a white nurture in
relationship I'm not sure you don't have
to say what was unacceptable
yeah yeah it's not acceptable so I
didn't want my daughters to then I I
think sometimes we rerun our parents
relationship no no I said no because
you're not allowed to say that word oh
oh you're not okay yeah so I just felt
like I'd see I just felt like I thought
it was acceptable because I grew up
seeing it so therefore I didn't want
them to think that was acceptable that
was how relationships were supposed to
be so I decided not to do it and when
you said to me 18 years you should have
stayed no way I believe in if if it's
unhappy it affects your kids worse
uh in the case of abuse I would agree
with you yeah in abuse but I think
that's more of the exception rather than
the rule because women leave 70 to 80
percent of the time 90 of were college
educated and one of the number one
predictors of if you're going to get a
divorce is if you out earn your husband
um
I think that's because of the women or
because of the men I think it's because
women are hypergamous and it's hard for
a woman to be attracted to a guy she
makes more than
um because in my personal circumstances
the issue I've always had is a man not
being secure enough to accept the fact
that I've done better than them I think
I think the problem you think you've
done better but yeah that's that's the
problem is like women and it kind of
shows in the way you talk respectfully
like it sounds like you like yeah it
sounds like you're acting like you're
better than that that's not what I mean
yeah but I'm saying a lot of like women
unintentionally act like they're better
than the guy and then it makes him
insecure but so the way you look is I
like for me personally obviously
everyone's different but for me
personally when I'm looking for a guy
I care about if what they're doing they
have passion for what they're doing they
have drive for what they're doing
regardless of how they are financially
because when you're with somebody you're
a couple right you're a team in that so
it doesn't matter who the higher earner
is it matters if they can provide you
with that emotional support and that
stability and I think that sounds nice
but that's just not women what women
pick and I think when we say things like
that it's dishonest but it's because it
is what happens no because women when
you survey women where they're not in
front of them on camera with mics in
their faces they say they want a guy
that makes at least 30 percent more than
them they say this this is from the
horse's mouth okay as yeah of course
I've never dated a guy that's that's
kind of uh more than I have well I mean
you also aren't married though so you
didn't stay with one
even kind of aligns with my experience
so Nigerian background the last
generation of Nigerians were very like
you know Pioneers they did very very
well Goldman Sachs and all the women
especially the women who did really well
are like found it extremely hard to
settle down because of that reason they
all said I need I need someone who's
like on better than me who's like earns
more than me and these women were like
top lawyers like they were like killing
it and they were all these guys they had
all the options they had the looks they
had all the physical assets that men
liked and they struggled for decades in
some cases and I think some of them
still aren't married now because and you
know Nigeria is very vocal so you go
into family you know reunions and
weddings and they weren't they weren't
shy of saying yeah like if you don't and
if you can't compete with me earnings
wise I've got a twin sister and you know
even then you kind of hear those kind of
sentiments
um or this idea that like if you settle
for someone who you know it doesn't earn
as much as in the six successful as you
are that you're like settling and this
is this could be like a six foot four
muscle bound uni educated women always I
mean why do we know the we know this
phrase when I say oh I want a Man On My
Level women say that all the time you
don't hear men saying oh I want a woman
on my level but do you think that's
because I think it's because women are
hypergamous and men aren't
women want a guy that they can look up
to I don't think it's a bad one that's
okay I think it's okay I actually agree
with that phrase I want a guy on my
level but that doesn't come down to a
monetary value alone money muscles frame
and game